welcome back to peers of organizing Kim
Jong-un of Vladimir Putin made out of
the Russian Spaceport today to talk
about potential weapons and satellite
technology deals the world's most deadly
and shortest dictators told the rocket
launch site before sitting down for a
press conference it talked about
prioritizing the Strategic importance of
North Korea Russia relations which
should send a send a shutter down all
our spines is this new warring
development in the real Star Wars or are
Kim and vladis trivial bit part players
in a new Global Space Race well who
better to ask than the world's what is
the most brilliant and the world's most
famous astrophysicist Neil deGrasse
Tyson so please have him back on the
show Neil great to see you
yeah thanks for having me thanks for
having me back so Kim Jong-un Vladimir
Putin and space seems an Unholy Trilogy
what is your view of what what went down
today
yeah I mean I you know I wasn't in the
conversation but seeing the images uh
it's it's a little bit worrisome because
space is is we've known for decades
though it's a it's a new high ground and
from a military strategic perspective
High Ground gives you power and power
that you didn't previously have so yes
this this Alliance of of Nations that
we're not friendly with uh now that
we're not friendly with concerns me but
what considers me even more is space can
be a place where we all come together
for peaceful purposes more so than
anything we might ever do on Earth's
surface so uh for me it's an extra
offense for anyone to speak of space
Weaponry because in space well yeah you
can have borders of countries on Earth
in space there are no borders right it's
just space and so it to me it's a
violation of a of a a human
our species contract with the universe
if I could call it yeah no when you saw
for example India launching Rockets
um last week I think it was I mean I
found that very uplifting to watch that
it's amazing to watch it exciting I
remember took me right back to the 60s
and 70s when I used to watch all the
rocket launches as a kid uh what did you
feel watching all that
yeah so uh you're probably talking about
the mission that where they landed near
the South Pole of the Moon as the
graphic there uh shows so they're the
first country to land in that part of
the Moon the South Pole might have a
repository of water trapped in the base
of craters where the sun don't shine
because the rim of the crater is higher
than the angle that the sun will ever
reach it and so the history of comet
impacts and other things water brought
to the Moon would evaporate where the
sun shines but stay forever where the
sun doesn't shine and so they're the
first there this was great they were
dancing in the streets yes and I I was
so and they become the fourth country to
softly land on the moon adjoining and so
the idea that this becomes a a world
where countries participate uh so that
it becomes the solar system becomes our
Collective backyard am I am I too naive
to think that that's possible I I don't
know well it's interesting
artificial intelligence you know a lot
of it is incredibly exciting and you
know wildly like you know you can go
into wild New Frontiers of potential and
of course there's another part of me
thinks this is going to be incredibly
dangerous because the wrong people will
get their hands on AI and do bad things
with it
yeah so that's a very important
observation to make because the press
that AI is getting today leads people to
think that all AI is bad when in my
field we've been using AI for decades at
some levels or another and every next
power of AI that comes on on online we
absorb it because we let it do the work
I don't want to do the work right I have
other things I can do yeah so so yeah it
shouldn't indict the entire Enterprise
of AI because you can imagine some parts
of AI turning Rogue so with space yeah I
I want space to be peaceful think about
it in the International Space Station it
is a joint project with Russia and the
United States and other countries so if
countries can't get along on Earth do
you expect astronauts in space to say
okay separate don't talk to each other
because our leaders can't get along
that's almost childish to expect that
when you have scientists and engineers
in space doing real interesting work two
stories near that when I saw them I
thought of you immediately one is that
scientists at Nasa have announced the
existence of a possible planet that
could sustain life
tell me about this
yeah so that's uh the James Webb Space
Telescope if it's the new story I'm
thinking about uh it has the power to
observe the atmosphere
and the chemical composition of the
atmosphere of exoplanets if the planet
passes in front of the host star light
from the host star will move through the
air and the chemicals in the atmosphere
will leave its fingerprint in the
spectrum that we receive and it found
methane it found carbon dioxide and
these consider these as biomarkers if
there's evidence of life on the surface
it may if there's life on the surface it
may manifest in the chemistry of the
atmosphere and it's in the Goldilocks
zone where you can sustain liquid water
too close the water evaporates too far
the water freezes everywhere there's
liquid water on Earth there's life if
not fishes then there's microbial life
so NASA's Mantra is follow the water if
you want to find life and if we so if
this so if I'm ready for the the list of
planets to go to uh we'll rank them
based on these kinds of evidence right
to say if if we want to have a second
Earth or move somewhere let's try this
one first and then the next one and then
the next one because plenty of the
exoplanets would be fully in
inhospitable to Life as We Know It
fascinating the other thing was UFOs of
the U.S Congress convened this panel
about unidentified anomalous phenomenon
uaps to try and work out what we do and
don't know
um at the same time as we're speaking
this is freaky but as we're speaking
about the Mexican Parliament someone's
just produced images of alien corpses uh
in the Mexican Parliament and said
they're alien corpses so I guess my
question for you Neil is do you believe
that there are loads of aliens out there
do you believe that governments perhaps
know more than we do
um and should we be fearful about this
yeah so first of all those are not
images of alien corpses in Mexico those
are presented as actual alien mummified
aliens from like a thousand years ago so
here's what you do when we went to the
moon we brought moon rocks back and NASA
allowed scientists of the world to
analyze those rocks it's shared samples
with everyone rather than give it to
only one lab so if those are actual
mummified aliens
found in Mexico or wherever they were I
overheard the press conference they said
they carbon 14 dated it it has 30
overlap DNA with humans if those are
aliens that would be amazing but in
science you need verification from
independent sources so what they should
do as we know from from mummies uh
there's still a soft tissue in the
mummies carbon 14 dated that I don't
know if he did it on the soft tissue or
on the bones but my point is you share
the data with other Laboratories and
when you have agreement among what is
measured then you can talk about it as a
discovery but the Press loves chasing
singular stories by one laboratory that
says no one else has this but we do
y'all just run to that and report it
like it's the truth so but science is
not established by single measurements
or observations
are you saying we tend to sensationalize
these things now
hahaha
yes you did yes you did let's take a
short break I want to come back and talk
about your brilliant new book to
infinity and beyond and about vegans and
about God maybe not even in that order
welcome back to Pittsburgh nonsense I'm
talking to you I'll give you the most
popular scientist in the universe ever
Professor Neil deGrasse Tyson whose new
book just to do a bit of media
sensationalism there Neil his new book
to infinity and beyond is out this month
it's it's absolutely riveting you write
about this stuff so brilliantly you
bring it all so alive
um I'm gonna go into a few of these but
first of all
the key question for me with all this
well especially I was reading your book
how much do you think we know and how
much do you think we don't know about
what's out there
that's a great question and I can
actually quantify that answer so there's
there are these things this dark matter
you might have heard about so dark
matter is 85 it's responsible for 85
percent of the gravity in the universe
and we have no idea what it is but we
can measure it there's Dark Energy
responsible for the accelerated
expansion of the universe we can measure
that but we don't know what's causing it
and then you add up all of these sort of
what these forces are doing in the
universe it's 96 of what's driving the
universe and all the forces of nature
that we know and love gravity uh
electromagnetism the strong and weak
nuclear forces life chemistry biology
physics that's in four percent of the
universe so we know enough about the
universe
to quantify our ignorance
so we know four percent of what's going
on out there but also keep in mind that
as the area of our knowledge grows
so too does the perimeter of our
ignorance
and that is the very soul of science
that they're questions people say what
questions do you want answered yeah I
don't think that way I think what
question do I not even yet know yes I
think that's the really interesting part
is that you're probably not even
thinking of a great question right
because there may be something correct
that's I I lose sleep over that yes no
how do you I know you're in a vowed
atheist how can you be so certain
that there is no Supernatural god-like
entity out there given that we know so
little
well first I I don't count myself among
the ranks of a valid atheists and I'll
give a fast example why a friend of mine
went up to fix the Hubble telescope okay
on the space shuttle and on my on my on
my Facebook feed I said godspeed to the
Space Shuttle astronauts and then in the
comment thread it said I thought you
were an atheist how could you possibly
say that and so the fact that I
gleefully said that and atheists
complained about it clearly I'm not an
atheist my favorite my favorite Broadway
musical of all time is Jesus Christ
Superstar which I saw in real time in
New York City and I don't know that
atheists so I don't so is there a goblin
nailed to Grass Tyson I'll be about to
have break time is there a God
okay so I will tell you is that with
there are a lot of unknowns in the
universe but just because they're
unknowns does not mean there's a deity
in the unknown if you're gonna it
doesn't mean there isn't that which
it doesn't mean there isn't that's
correct your mind about this right
I everyone should if the the unknown is
the unknown but the the the the track
record of people saying God is behind
this and then you add a little science
to it and you find out no we can
completely explain it and control it
then that the history of that exercise
is so rich with science
discovering the unknowns that were
previously ascribed to deity like
lightning bolts and weather systems
there was Poseidon there was Zeus there
was just look at the history of this I'm
I'm not given reason to say we're going
to find something God is going to be at
the center of that and there'll be no
science to apply I'm going to look for
the science first because that's how the
history of this exercise has unfolded I
want to play you a clip this is you
talking to Joe Rogan about vegans
you want to save animals
um I never seen I've never seen anyone
say
save the leeches no no one cares about
bugs save the ticks and you can ask
if you really into animals and don't
want to kill them if you heard that
ticks were endangered would you start a
movement to protect ticks would you do
that
and if you would more power to you but
I'm thinking you're not they're not it's
the little guys they don't care about
I've had this debate with vegans I won
last week I have it every month and I
always point out most vegans I know
Munch away on almonds and avocados and
they turn a blind eye to the fact that
this causes the mass murder of billions
of bees mainly in California they don't
want to have that debate because they
don't care about the little guy's meal
yeah my my only reaction there is
um that comment was addressing only
vegans who are vegans because they don't
want to kill animals other reasons to be
vegan
Healthcare I want to kill the ones who
run into steakhouses playing sounds of
cows being slaughtered they're the ones
that Munch avocados and almonds
invariably yeah and by the way and they
are dining upon the reproductive organs
of plants that's kind of weird and I
imagine if if a plant-based alien
visited Earth they would freak out when
they saw vegetarians yes because the
veterans would be eating them right and
and and vegetarians Target not only the
reproductive organs the nuts the berries
the flowers but they also Target the
infant versions of it with baby lettuce
baby carrots baby this would terrify a
plant-based alien so that's just a
cosmic perspective on that no no you've
given me you have given me a whole new
line of attack
the the flower babies I love it this is
fantastic uh I I I just they I find this
that's the way that's dangerous if it's
dangerous to feed you more lines of
attack because I don't know what you're
gonna do with it but I always like to
take these things to their debates to
their logical end right I mean and it
seems to me they when it suits them they
care about the bigger animals the cuddly
ones but when it comes to the little
guys they're not interested um now I
want to talk about sorry the furry ones
especially something even more iconic
actually the god or vegans and it's your
mustache which has become one of the
world's most famous mustaches and his
extraordinary there's a whole website
that's been set up called deGrasse
Tyson's mustache and we did a bit of
research ourselves a bit of scientific
research uh and there's a mustache
Montage that we have here which is quite
extraordinary it turns out almost every
brilliant scientist has had a
magnificent Tash Nikola Tesla the
inventor extraordinaire great Tash Louis
de broglie the discovered the wave-like
nature of all matter great Tash Hans
Geiger famous for the geiger counter
Robert H Goddard built the first liquid
fueled rocket and of course Albert
Einstein probably the one nearest to
your own
um you I mean you've become the modern
day Godfather of science mustaches but
very much
running in a sort of a great long
historic list of great tashes
I I never thought about it that this
mustache I've never shaved it in my life
yes I've trimmed it but it's ever since
I could grow a mustache I've had a
mustache so uh it's just part of my life
and even it was kind of out of style a
few years ago and I I was a little bit I
did get rid of my mutton chop sideburns
I figured okay that's from 1978 I could
lose those but I did keep the mustache
but if I were to vote among those
Mustangs yes I would say you know we
remember Einstein is this wire-haired
yeah you know gray big bushy eyebrows
but he was a dashing young man you see
him in a tuxedo yes look at that
mustache that's like a Magnum PI
mustache right there if you could final
question Neil if you could have dinner
tonight with any scientist in the
history of recording mankind who would
it be
yeah it would be oh no question about it
Isaac Newton but I think about that all
the time and I'd say Isaac come for
dinner and he'd look out the window and
he'd see these things moving he said
what are those and I said well they're
horse-drawn carriages without a horse he
said well how do they move when they use
gasoline what's gasoline oh it's fossil
fuels what's fossil fuels and after five
minutes it is I say go back to it
also unfortunately your answer there's
so much that has happened since then
well you're awesome I don't know if I
have the patience well you killed my
theory also because Isaac Newton
famously it was clean shaven
oh
well um Newton we see him with these big
locks of curls but I think that was
actually a wig on top of much shorter
hair and the statue of him in Cambridge
at the in Trinity in a church in
Cambridge
um it's you shoot you see him with short
hair wow so I was so disappointed when I
heard of that yeah
Neil I could honestly interview every
single day and it would never get boring
you've got a fantastic way of bringing
this stuff to life to infinity and
beyond a journey of cosmic Discovery
Neil deGrasse Tyson and Lindsay Walker
it's the number one New York Times
bestseller as all your books are it's a
fantastic reading great to have you back
in uncensor thank you
thank you